hello everybody just my name is Mark
Abbar I'm back with drunk minecraft and
these guys are betrayed and captain
farkles yeah farkles M&R collegia
myrtles camp are khals calves orbital's
camp our goals we're back and we're
gonna build some gnarls barkley why is
there so much to doing what shoes
sparkles what's happening what happened
oh I I really don't know it's like a
tornado
fire tornado why there's a tornado of
fire excuse me there is where the hell
are you talking about how building works
well I'm gonna I'm gonna assume that you
two douches are incapable of seeing
something correctly and there was
actually nothing Oh guys I was
introduced this time whoa whoa Wow it's
a beautiful fire it's a tornado
explosions oh so now you know you do see
it now now yeah but now it's real before
you were just lying uh-huh hey anyway
we're gonna build some it's cursed can
we can we feel Slenderman again oh
listen I mean we're not building Goku in
Virginia No wasn't that in Oni and Jesus
oh right well peepee terrible baby I
love that what's up with those so funny
oh god it was so funny but anyway um I
wanna be Oh gonna build slimmin whoa oh
dear oh dear oh dear
can we make the oh my can we make all
that the extra return of Slendy sniffles
can we can we do can we do the double
return of Lindy's nipples you guys want
to see another sinners state let's watch
episode inserted I wish the water would
come the water does our Cossack zombie
has to make the water oh my god just
look at this mess magical just look at
it forming look at the related forming
the river bed yeah yes we're looking we
see make sure your water the water is
filling in from the other boy Wow
whatever it was Bob what did you do I
made them how does this river look like
part of a penis over here hey you look
like penis River that's cuz I'm a manly
rivers y'all we're doing a great what
you just wrote this is who invited this
alcoholic guy anyway yeah I drink in now
you know
now oh I just cooked drinks from two
different directions at once oh god I
feel like we never mind we're drinking
no they don't need to know
mm-hmm mine's really big so they can see
it
oh we make it day can it be day now
Oh God can I go now good after a whole
mixed drink tastes like rotting rectum
oh my god wait whoa wait back up how do
you know what rotting rectum case laughs
yeah how do you how do you know Wade
well not with you too much whoa whoa
whoa your diary into a horrible horrible
place I feel really insecure right now
gave me an egg sack
yeah you take that egg sack you take it
oh yeah you like that in sec well here
have some of this is where this where
are you through this we're back by the
remnants of the town you're picking up
everything you want to throw at me I'll
take this yeah you like some of this
whoa I die so quickly
oh gosh I didn't know the ink sacs could
kill chickens so effectively by the way
where are you guys cuz I don't worry
we're backwards
the river follow here Jesus died he'd
come on shaken oh I feel like this is
animal cruelty and Peter's gonna get
upset with you oh yeah free dinner for
everyone for thanks yeah but that's
turkey not chicken zombie your sugar
sure has improved as of late it can
handle all the people and space stations
don't even get turkeys what no don't
wait they don't I thought they did they
get like freeze-dried turkey and stuff
well that's not the same but it's still
dead I mean it has the same molecules in
it
it does how do you know because have you
been a space actually if you think of it
no molecular I reserved a flight on
Virgin Galactic ha ha
we passed that boat a long time ago good
idea yeah we want virgin kill fast ha ha
these are the jokes everybody these are
the jokes all human offspring all die
you keep dying over anyway all right
back to business and I'm gonna drink
here it's Goku and he's got Super Saiyan
that's well there okay let's go ku
structure all right oh wait wait wait
is that his face like goes its face
Super Saiyan me can we make a working
touch which phallic object we arrive we
try wants me I tried to make a working
piece get it it just didn't work it just
didn't work like it's like you try
making it did you try making a TNT
cannon or no no I have the best idea
whoa do it and I are gonna do it are you
okay you know how we're gonna do it
laughs there whoa phallic object again
know how we're gonna do it what the hell
Goku's got an infected I have sores
hold on here's how we're gonna do it I
need this sorry I need to break off the
tiny break off the tip a little bit all
right
wait so you actually know how to make
this work cuz we've tried yeah yeah I
know how to make it work oh we got a mic
right at present we don't need to build
a a new statue or anything it would have
to do another look you're clogging this
up with chickens yeah see this is why
wait is I don't know you were digging a
hole okay so hold on I'm making Goku I'm
making Goku we already had him no I'm
making him better go through oh oh are
Goku ain't good enough for
CaptainSparklez oh he's gotta make one
of those like ass weird Chinese gang
symbol blue screen wait let's go come on
oh I see it now oh if you really if you
really wait wait mmm dude that's Goku
after he went super saiyan that Super
Saiyan seven with way too much hair yeah
he's like cousin it with the face that's
a good reference 90 people yeah I think
I need to give him a body sorry but
subscribe and read Oggy
okay scratch that one um let me see let
me see what how am I gonna twit colour
would his skin be uh Oh making out of
birch wood means her make it out of
birch wood oh no where's wood blocks
best face ever hey zombie can we get a
temp blank template person giant can we
can you get that ass fat no no no that's
cheating you weirdo cheating is what we
do is it familiar with our way okay hold
on hold on here we go and I wrote this
horse ha boutique's going to this horse
I broke it Hey no what's wrong
hey is it just this is erosion or
something or is it okay to the server
died oh the severed tongue oh my Goku
zombi had to get the template we did it
there's only one wait wait I got wait
wait oh wait wait are you very super say
she would not be happy come on oh no
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it hold
on it's gonna be the best come on out
out out out out out what are you doing
it turned cold because he's super saying
I think only his pubic hair and gold
like just you know the pubic hair down
there is just like spikes as well see
that's a question that was unanswered
throughout the series is what color does
that turn at yeah because no one there
ever had chest hair or anything like
that or even like armpit hair they just
had like hair on their head and knows it
except for a little but no but I mean to
be there like in the original Dragon
while there are some really perverted
scenes to be today yeah yeah you're
right you're definitely right there but
you get gold why no that's actually
that's too floppy whoa what it needs to
beat straighter yeah I don't know what
misshapen horror that you were but
you're on drug minecraft we have a bit
of professionalism when it comes to our
penises so weird
hey guys here's a challenge go back put
the comment section how many penises
have been built in this series give us
an accurate number yeah anything to
anything that we set it only is what we
say is a penis counts as a penis like if
we went back look step back if you like
go to penis that's only what goes may or
may not count
good God Bob where'd you go how are the
horse in the sky my horse died okay how
big should it be what you have to put me
inside don't think that qualifies as
anything Bobby I mean we're being a
little rude to goku here cuz i'm i'm
stepping back a bit you don't really
mean because oh look at this you know
you're okay horrifying me right now -
why is it dripping like a faucet I can't
watch oh my god okay okay so hold on oh
my god okay alright okay now we're gonna
do it for realsies
alright let me inside then I don't know
if he's gonna work with you in there
hold on what kind of cannon is this RC
RC I'm curious as to how Kevin's burgled
what you have planned like seriously
this looks like what's gonna happen
looks like a thing oh my god oh no the
black ball black ones no no no no no no
don't no don't do that don't do that oh
my god Jesus we caught on fire oh you
guys this guy needs a doctor oh my god
Oh Bob did you not taking part in the
Bob did you just get here don't do that
don't do that no no don't do you see
don't see why Wade is a giant piece [ __ ]
Jesus I'm trying to make a professional
yeah yeah we know
but wait here things operate I think
that chickens are better suited than
sheep at this okay see this is gonna
know what are the Sheep cut out the
chickens are not better suited than the
sheep because the chickens just they
they hover as they they glide as they go
so I'm gonna step back a bit you do your
thing thank of it step back a little bit
I just have to do this for a while why
is my face on the peanuts why is my face
of air out of ass why why is barking
that you've been there oh oh I see yeah
it's your face all over wouldn't that be
horrible
thank you Falls and like in that
commercial do you ever see that
commercial where I've never seen a
commercial with faces on a penis no no
in the PU uh Bob cabin you like that
commercial where people's heads were
down in people's crotches what what
commercial Oh knows a music video or
something like that what it was messed
up man people like in the comment rate
comment and subscribe if you know that
commercial where people had really
crotches I'm not joking
Thanks description nice description oh
people will know what I'm tired but Bob
he's innocent
Bob what are we gonna start this episode
it's late okay okay okay here you hear a
hold on here we go okay so ready yeah I
forgot your faces all over here we go
here's everyone I'm ready I'm ready I'm
ready okay ready baby three two one wait
wait in three two one
no one in three two one God whoa extra
drip at the end oh my god
best job Oh kill it zombie kill this Oh
turn it into dandy I'll kill it killer
is fire yes did I go Club I'm so sorry
oh my god
what would this be a TN teenis
um uh a TN
tong okay I don't know oh that's not
gonna feel good when it gets to go who
in the end was no match for candy alive
this rib cage oh my god oh my god
zombie is there a vegeta model sara
rependa monologues
i think that i would what are you
talking about we built this yeah we
built you see oh yeah you forgot you've
been drinking a bit too much we should
we should play jousting testing how do
you do tasks or we should do um
currently on a horse I'm trying to think
of a good thing to joust this they don't
have green eyes I feel we may have made
his eyes the wrong color
um yeah when he was super saying they
turned green okay
yeah yeah leave I get a shirt childhood
hero you know what I didn't remember the
exact color maybe you should have looked
into his eyes more forcefully I'm sorry
Oh what's his nose is lopsided it's not
okay they're gonna wear I still kind of
funky yeah we're still pretty we're not
I'm gonna make his nose his nose hairs
are gold is really God is Regina oh god
it's a little bit smaller than Goku ages
Alito
no Mike it's all he's got a Scouter oh
you feel together he does oh my god oh
my god I can tell this could happen to
his arms yeah well I wait I'll fix that
I'll fix that
Oh Oh to me Oh put a jack-o'-lantern on
his crotch I would never laughing
because wait a little guys that's good
oh this is why we can't have nice video
why is there a wood coming up wait no no
wait no
Vegeta's drooling because he sees Bulma
right across the way please let there be
a bull's-eye appropriable the statue
yeah not a horribly inappropriate one
but a semi appropriate one Susan I am
like googling like crazy right yeah it's
nice that we let him prepare for this
for so long
yes he comes up with all these plans and
things we can do no Bobo's game it's a
really elaborate game I spend a lot of
time working on you guys want to play it
no no no okay I get one no now it's nine
guys guys guess what
oh I know where this is going we have to
make a bow I was gonna do that
no you weren't it was my job you you
forgot part of it how do you make the
sound of guys guys guys guys guys guys
we have to make a boma okay right at our
job oh we can only use birch wood blue
and pink Church with blue and pink haha
alright okay alright maybe we should use
colors for clothing otherwise she's
gonna be nude nope nope oh wait I can't
make birch wood go sideways oh yes I can
you can just use the planks why is that
the planks are we using the Rahway the
raw wood way Xabi can we get a blank
model like just a blank across from
facing vegeta across the way or facing
away to show what wait she could be
tying her shoes look be now it's done
kid begging over wait a minute hey look
it's not a fleshly that's the no no hair
oh okay we're gonna turn this into
bowmen I'm gonna fix the face hahahaha
are you gonna do
fix me the same thing I always do to
your face wait I die here over the world
sport Wow well so he took care of my
face
looks like woman down so that feat I
just got rid of the faith oh those diet
I mean those could be those could be the
red dot straight down there you know
they could be you know oh oh boy oh yeah
oh yeah
Dec will she be having a nosebleed Oh Oh
Wade yo buddy material mark what the
hell are you doing don't ya that's all
what's that's not virtual is that you
shut your mouth are we just using
whatever material is closed is that
we're giving her another sausage penis
nippled mark what the hell is this what
is this god I'm actually curious what is
it and you know what what whatever you
know what you know whatever whatever
material we want that's what this game
is you know what there's another ball ma
ma that's not oh ha ha oh it's a white
person really really I may have
overstated my balance here shut up
Oh zombie porn in whatever you want do
whatever you'd like
ha ha ha ha ha oh my how dare you how
dare you long this person might have
degeneration I'm gonna drain it hey
let's let's all drink for a second I
thought we were drinking ah is there wha
what's happening Oh
Hey well we have one Eid and one part
can't even build anything you guys won't
let us I got the hair going you guys I
haven't done much it much I have done
much oh yeah that's gorgeous
gulia house get out of my house way I'm
fixing it up you hired a painter let me
paint it Alma it is it yeah hey it
doesn't look like Bulma no no trying to
build Birchwood face cuz Birchwood faces
creepy face let me build birds would
face are you really a skeleton in there
what oh my gosh there's nothing
underneath here oh this is not good I
guess you could actually the same
principle could apply here hold on you
can apply the same principle connote
apply to what you don't have protect
this the same principle could apply to
this okay boo-boo bum bum bum bum bum
copyright copy that song is definitely
not copyrighted cuz they'll do all these
balls
how old are balls how old are you are
you the same age as balls
I believe that your balls are the same
age that you are but not other way to
get one nipple I get the other okay Y is
1 Y is 1 chicken and Y is I don't have a
wait wait why are these nipple penises
yeah I do not understand how this works
hey don't tell me how to run my own show
alright drug my ground I owe you since
episode one mark telling me what how to
run your show ha ha ha ha I've ever as
I've stated one it's a baby sheep baby
sheep this is not age-appropriate for
you ha ha
at the fall and die I want people the
one quote to come out of this episode is
why are there nipple penises is the
Koala
that's gonna be the name of the vapor
sit it's gonna be the name of the
episode
why are you can just appearing with that
who's spying the chins we're smiling
sighs okay I'm over here hmm
so when are we gonna fire these bad boys
the only thing the only thing I don't
like about the Sheep is that
occasionally okay what is this what is
it
Oh wire that nice addition Bob that's
lovely nice thank you
I think there's some housing you're
somehow causing the the chicken to spaz
out there Bob I'm gonna win the race I
hear a lot of clicking happening all
right let's do that I'm gonna drink more
okay drink you're 40
I think it's lies not the 40 that's Bob
sparkling oh sorry sorry I couldn't
remember the funny a Newton I'm gonna
let this bad boy out
boom wait that oh that yeah that was my
six and now it's just hovering there I
don't know like it's slow down now it's
still motion this does not work so much
oh my god oh my god did he clearly
weaken so we just clear to use clear the
sheep that I spent five minutes putting
in
oh no no they're in there they're in
there are they busy just get out the
game is so glitch in what happens if I
go in there can we all Knights how you
are there that many or did it I feel
like okay we're gonna everyone gets
spawn sheep everyone everyone everyone
gets barred sheep we're gonna make this
right we're doing all of them all of the
shape makes bump right them just start
clicking a lot if you need to you can
build you can do this here you can click
higher up so more people can do it at
once
okay yeah I don't think this is what we
got there they're going about not
working oh don't do that don't do that
now I see some door that you're ruining
everything my frame rate my nipple penis
is full oh they're jumping out here
break the other one I'm gonna stand down
again there's still a whole Monday yeah
Vegeta looks like he is enjoying this
that's why he's drooling zombie get rid
of all this kill everything with fire
preferably all we've accomplished the
bail bonds I'll be just turned the
entire grass to TNT and please and then
didn't brush everything end this please
and this no one needs to know that this
ever happened that's funny cuz we
recorded it shut up oh my god goes drool
everybody oh my god
is to beat maybe God but Vegeta's drool
Kazan is so beautiful
good god oh yeah
it's still going it's not stopping
anytime soon
oh my god wow it's beautiful it away
mm-hmm yes I'll be definitely improved
his servers like he transferred to a new
server it is like good yeah I am very
surprised this is holding okay go all
right I think yeah the episode ended
when all that [ __ ] went down I guess
okay so can I stop the recording this
time since I think that you guys are
doing your thing after the race yes what
do you think of drunk minecraft think it
was fantastic I know best minecraft
using penis is where we're really great
hahahaha though can you post this from
your perspective probably this one may
be the last one thank you guys so much
for bye-bye everyone
know I'd ended a long time ago oh I just
decide where I cut it I don't know where
fade to black and then end and then clip
me flicking off the camera in at the end
yeah I looked at people like that yeah
what wait a minute
way to back up a second wait wait and
end it ha ha ha I'm legit laughing you
guys are fake laugh he knows that's my
real laugh